today on january 6th we commemorate a
glorious event
we remember the wise men who traveled a
great distance for their leader the true
leader of us all
in defiance of an unjust government the
celebrations today will be wonderful
but can you imagine the blessedness of
having actually been there
when the event took place
an event that changed the world
infinitely
for the better
i'm michael knowles and this is the
feast of the epiphany
[Music]
welcome back to the show
what a wonderful day boy do i love
january 6th my favorite comment from
sergio soto who says i'm not just
celebrating january 6th once but twice
celebration number one the epiphany
celebration number two
my birthday
oh that's what that's wonderful even
more reasons to celebrate
january 6th
you know
the celebration on january 6th is when
it recognizes when the magi following
the star made it to
bethlehem
to behold the baby jesus
and to bring him gifts
of frankincense and myrrh
and gold and when you want to acquire
gold i would strongly recommend you
check out birch gold i am so excited to
talk about a brand new sponsor to the
show that sponsor this is a sponsor that
i have wanted on this show for years at
this point i frankly i kind of feel like
i made it
i'm talking about birch gold birch gold
a wonderful company and a really
important one right now because
inflation is at 40-year highs and it is
here to stay why well here's the
government's dirty little secret the
government
wants inflation they want inflation
because right now inflation rates are
higher than the interest on treasury
bonds which means that with every day
that passes the government owes less on
its mountain of debt imagine if you had
a negative interest rate on your
mortgage would you be in any hurry to
pay that off i don't think so so your
pain is their gain protect your savings
now do it with
gold from birch gold wonderful hedge
against inflation the government is
sabotaging the value of the u.s dollar
so allow birch gold to help you convert
an eligible ira or 401k into an ira
backed by real gold that is peace of
mind
with thousands of satisfied customers an
a plus rating for the better business
bureau you can trust birch gold to
protect your savings text knowles candy
wles to 989898
to get a free info kit on holding gold
in a tax sheltered account
then call birch and protect your
hard-earned savings text knowles
k-w-l-e-s to 98-98
98
that's canon wles text it get your free
info kit right now
that was the greatest transition
ever to be done in the history of this
show miraculous you might call it and
that makes perfect sense because today
we celebrate this wonderful miracle the
star that leads the magi
to bethlehem to behold
the lord of the world
is any did anything else happen today
nothing of note as far as i'm concerned
the reason i keep bringing up
january 6th as being the feast of the
epiphany is one because it's a genuinely
wonderful holiday and we should
acknowledge it
but two
because we need to just ignore the lib's
histrionics about january 6th the worst
insurrection the day that our sacred
capitol building was when the day that
what happened the day that
some people
busted into the capitol that some people
were just
allowed in were welcomed in threw open
doors
no one died as the newspapers told us
they did no there were no governments
were overturned
a guy in a horn hat danced around and
some other smiley guy took nancy
pelosi's lecture and now they're all
rotting away
in prison that's
the issue here that the left understands
that the right
apparently has forgotten
is that all politics is religious you
might not want it to be religious you
might want to have a firm separation of
church and state keep your religion out
of my politics but it's not possible as
cardinal manning says all human conflict
ultimately is theological if we say that
politics is downstream of culture as
many conservatives do you got to
remember culture is downstream of cult
of religion that's what's at the basis
of all of our politics and the left
understands this and uses it to their
advantage this is how george floyd who
was a career criminal criminal an
unrepentant career criminal
became canonized as
the greatest martyr and saint in recent
memory this is how january 6 became a
sacred feast day a major feast day on
the secular liturgical calendar
all cultures
have religious views have religious
practices have religious feast days and
so what the left has done is kicked out
all the old normal good ones and replace
them with their crazy secular saints and
secular feast days and secular rituals
and this is also why
the conservatives who are spending all
day defending january so january 6 then
defending the horn hat guy or whatever
they're a little bit misguided too
it's a losing game
however you react to january 6th then
the capital and the insurrection however
you react to it you are playing into the
left's hands whether you're defending it
whether you're bemoaning it and saying
i'm sorry it was horrible it was either
way
you were granting the left's absurd
premise that this relatively trivial
political event especially trivial when
you consider the actual insurrection
that took place for a year with blm
riots attacking federal courthouses and
killing dozens of people
when you when you look at this true
relatively trivial political event and
you pretend
and you accept the left-wing premise
that the horn hat guy dancing in the
capital rotunda was some sort of world
historic event which it was not
okay it's a lose-lose thing
what i would recommend you do as as i
intend to do
is
just ignore the lib's histrionics don't
grant the premise it it just in the
grand scheme of american politics the
insurrection just it just wasn't that
big a deal i or will i know we're not
allowed to say that
but in the truly in the grand scheme of
all the threats to our republic of all
the insurrections that of all the
attacks on the capitol there have been
many attacks on the capital of all the
insurrections even from the year running
up to
january 6th
it it just wasn't that important
okay so what i would recommend you do is
spend january 6th
praying it's good
maybe go to church
and maybe have a nice meal with your
family if you can maybe fight to make
the country a better place
and and don't take the bait from the
libs a lot of a lot of people are doing
that donald trump gets this he totally
gets this
president trump i didn't even know he
had scheduled this
but he had scheduled
a press conference
for the anniversary of january 6th
and had i known that he had done that i
would have advised him to cancel the
press conference but didn't even need to
because he already canceled it he
sent out a memo you can't say he tweeted
anymore because he got booted from
twitter but he sends out these press
releases which are just tweets
and then he sends them out and then
people tweet the pictures of them so
this is what he said in light of the
total bias and dishonesty of the january
6th the unselect committee of democrats
because they're not they're not the
highest selection
two failed republicans and the fake news
media i am cancelling the january 6
press conference at mar-a-lago on
thursday and instead we'll discuss many
of those important topics at my rally on
saturday january 15th in arizona i look
forward to seeing our great american
patriots in arizona next weekend for a
big rally to save america totally the
right thing to do donald trump maybe you
hate the guy maybe you love the guy
donald trump understands politics and he
understands stagecraft
and he understands when he's in a
winning situation where he can get a big
win and he understands when you're in a
situation and you can't get a win
the way the libs have framed january 6th
is a complete loser
you can't win if you play into it and so
he recognized this and he said okay
never mind whatever we're gonna have
january 15th that's gonna be the new big
day and we're gonna have a big rally and
we're gonna talk about how great america
is and we're not gonna buy into their
nonsense and the myriad lies that they
told about what actually happened at the
capitol lies such as the the rioters
killing a police officer brian sicknick
with it was just completely made up so
yeah we're going to ignore that we're
just going to move on he had the right
idea we should follow course because
donald trump knows a thing or two about
politics he knows a whole lot about
stagecraft and show business and he's
right and he's looking pretty good right
now by the way
i don't know if you've been paying
attention to the current occupant of the
oval office
but he's not
particularly popular
there's a new poll out from cnbc and
change research
this is not a right-wing poll this is a
left-wing poll they surveyed voters
between december 17th and december 20th
they found that joe biden's disapproval
numbers
are now at 56 percent
a clear
majority of americans
disapprove
of joe biden's presidency
the same poll same outlet
uh was was done in april they found his
disapproval was 49 they they took the
same poll in september as 54
now it's gone even further up to 56 the
trend line is not in the right direction
for
biden
nobody believes that joe biden is the
most popular president ever elected
remember that was the claim the
democrats said joe biden got 80 million
votes
he got 80 bazillion votes the most votes
ever of any president's the most
popularly elected president ever now of
course the democrats changed all the
rules right right before the election so
the election is not comparable to other
elections and this was a point glenn
beck made before the 2020 election glenn
beck who's fairly moderate actually in a
lot of areas and he was asked his
thoughts on the 2020 election it's not
as though he loved donald trump he
opposed trump the first time i think he
voted for him the second time and glenn
said
that no one's going to trust the results
of this election because it's not being
conducted like other elections
so you extend election day now it's
election month you have widespread
unsolicited mail-in ballots you've got
the the
disrespecting of the constitutional
provisions of elections in pennsylvania
for instance you've got days and weeks
to count the ballots afterwards so
people weren't gonna gonna trust it
and that's true a lot of republicans
especially don't trust the results of
the election
with a lot of reason not to trust it
democrats did not trust the results of
the 2016 election actually
a higher percentage of democrats did not
trust the results of the 2016 election
as republicans not trusting the results
of the
2020 election so when you want to hear
about eroding faith and democracy and
and a threat to our republic look at the
democrats in 2016 and they had far less
reason to because it's not as though
that we changed all of the election
rules right before the 2016 election but
still there was not a lot of trust in
that election
either democrats in particular have sown
distrust in the elections going back to
the 2000 election terry mcauliffe who
was running for governor of virginia he
just lost he he refused to concede the
2000 presidential election this year
this past election year so
there are a lot of questions about the
elections one thing i can tell you
looking at these poll numbers right now
and it's not just the disapproval rating
among republicans it's democrats too
if joe biden were somehow to be
re-elected in 2024 given his situation
right now
nobody would believe it
jill dr jill wouldn't even believe it
that's how bad he's doing
he's breaking down the whole
administration's breaking down now when
your car breaks down what you're going
to want to do is go check out rock auto
the weather's getting pretty cold
there's snow or there's ice out there
people are driving they're going to see
their families for christmas and new
year they're going driving on vacation
and sometimes that car needs a tune-up
so when you need a part for your car or
truck where are you going to go are you
going to go to the brick and mortar auto
parts store where you go in
you gotta wait to see when they're open
you drive over there that's 15 minutes
you go in you wait in line it's another
five minutes and you get up there you
say hey you have this part for they say
what what car do you have you say i
don't know it's a 2012
uh honda
is it the ex answer like 5 000 questions
he goes in the back the guy doesn't even
have the part there's just too many
parts there's too many mixing models of
course then he orders it you pay twice
as much you wait two weeks you want to
do that or or
do you just go to rockauto.com that's
the answer family business serving auto
parts customers online for 20 years
rockauto.com they've got all the parts
you need for your car truck they've got
the easiest to navigate website ever
head on over rockauto.com right now see
all those parts available for your car
or truck and then write knowles
k-n-o-w-l-e-s
in the how did you hear about us box so
they know that we sent you
speaking of undemocratically elected
leaders the pope is in hot water pope
francis
pope francis
often gets into hot water
for being reported as having made
leftist comments
according to the reports his comments
can be very unorthodox heretical you
might even say left just marx as some
people have said but this time the pope
is in trouble
for making comments that are
too conservative
this time the pope is in trouble
with the liberals why because he said
that it is selfish
for couples to have pets instead of
children
this is a favorite topic of mine
because i love children and i hate pets
i don't like i'm a people person okay i
don't like them
and a lot of my friends
choose to have pets instead of children
here's what the pope said
we
saw i'm not going to put on my papa
francesco voice but you can imagine what
it sounded like this is what he said in
english we see that people do not want
to have children or just one and no more
and many many couples do not have
children because they do not want to or
they just have one
but they have two dogs
two cats yes dogs and cats take the
place of children yes it's funny i
understand but it is the reality and
this denial of fatherhood and motherhood
diminishes us it takes away our humanity
and in this way civilization becomes
aged and without humanity because it
loses the richness of fatherhood and
motherhood and our homeland suffers
as it does not have children
100 correct not only correct but urgent
and everyone needs to hear this and
everyone needs to deal with this and you
might not like it but it's it's the
truth
here are some ways that the pope is
being misconstrued
are you
are you telling me
holy father that that i'm selfish
because i can't have children
the pope never said that
a lot of people can't have children it's
very sad i myself sweet little elise and
i struggled
we thought we were gonna pop out a kid
right away when we got married and it
actually took a little while
we thought for a while we might not be
able to have children that was a cause
of immense pain as it is for people who
suffer with infertility
not everyone is able to have kids
it's very different not to be able to
have children and to just choose not to
because you want to pursue your own
interests
are you telling me holy father that
i i'm selfish because i love my dog no
the pope didn't say that it's fine to
love your dog but
it's different to love your dog
than it is to
treat your dog as a child
or have your dog be the replacement for
a child because you don't want to make
the commitment to having a child
are you telling me holy father pope
francis that it is
selfish of me to just want to pursue my
career and my interests and my desires
and my pleasures and prioritize that
over having a family
yes that is that's selfish it's super
duper selfish sorry it's
are you telling me holy father this is
the other one i've heard holy father
pope francis you are celibate you're not
married you don't have any kids how dare
you and there's a pot call in the kettle
black no pope francis didn't say that
everyone needs to get married
pope francis didn't say that some people
can't be celibate or have consecrated
religious life or consecrated say no he
didn't say that he said couples though
and they should it's true married
couples have an obligation to be open
to life
it's just a fact and if we don't do that
our civilization is going to die
and we're also going to be unhappy and
we're going to not be doing the things
that we're not and we're not going to be
giving fully of ourselves to our beloved
and our spouse but also our whole
civilization's going to die okay because
the pope isn't the only one saying this
elon musk
made this point another very important
figure from very different sectors
of society elon musk just came out he
said i can't emphasize this enough there
are not enough people
musk said this to the wall street
journal and i think one of the biggest
risks to civil civilization is the low
birth rate and the rapidly declining
birth rate and yet so many people
including smart people think that there
are too many people in the world and
think that the population is growing out
of control it's completely the opposite
please look at the numbers if people
don't have more children civilization is
going to crumble mark my words he's
absolutely right we've had a dying
population in this country for decades
and it's recently gotten a lot worse and
that's true throughout the civilized
west it's just collapsing and
the way that the ruling class tries to
prop up the civilization is just by
importing a ton of foreigners and that's
causing a lot of problems too huge
problems of assimilation this is the
largest movement of people in the
history of the world
and you're seeing the problems with that
all around you
but you can't do that forever you can't
just
replace all the people because they're
dying and getting old and not having any
children and then expect to have the
exact same civilization it's not going
to work
you need
you need to have kids this is a major
major issue
and what you will hear from people and
this is a perfectly legit concern
is well the not legit concern you're
going to hear is how dare you i want to
go work at the widget factory and you
can't tell me what to do and
who are you to say this and uh maybe
it's not right for me no i who am i to
say this i don't know i'm a person with
semi-functioning faculties of reason and
a moral conscience in a historical sense
and we actually can make public
statements about the way people behave
that's what society is that's what
politics is so yes we can we can say
it's better to do this than to do that
people should do this they shouldn't do
that we should discourage good things
and or we should encourage good things
we should discourage bad things but the
legit the legit concern is
kids are expensive kids are expensive
wages have completely stagnated in some
cases they've declined
the working class has gotten absolutely
crushed relative to the ruling class
everyone is swimming in mountains of
debt
the sexual revolution has destroyed the
relationship between men and women
there are now very few inducements to
marriage the supreme court completely
redefined marriage that didn't help
things either and so it's difficult
it's difficult and it's expensive and we
don't have the resources to do it
yes that's true
it is true if we want to have a society
that produces more kids then we're going
to have to have less stuff
you're not going to be able to buy as
much nice stuff or go to as many nice
restaurants or get as much delicious
avocado toast or drink these expensive
fruity seltzer drinks that i like so
much that i usually just pill for from
the daily wire you're not going to be
able to have as many luxuries if you
have kids you're right but that's part
of what pope francis is saying he's
saying it is selfish to prioritize your
own immediate pleasures over having a
child so yeah you will have to deal with
that and there is there is a criticism
of conservatives the criticism is this
you conservatives you're talking all
about family values and having lots of
kids and and rebuilding the civilization
but you don't want to support anybody
with any money you're stingy you're
greedy conservatives now this is mostly
a canard
conservatives for instance give more
money to charity than liberals do and
it's not even close even the new york
times has even admitted this
but
there there has been a sense on the
right
that we don't support social programs
we don't support welfare certainly not
at the federal level there's been a
little bit of this
ein rand fend for yourself pull yourself
up by your bootstraps ideology on the
right that is shallow and doesn't work
in every situation
so let me correct the record
because i think that there's a
caricature of what it meant to be a
republican in the 80s and i don't think
that's really
what it means to be a republican now
i
would fully support
a
government program with some
stipulations you'd obviously need
safeguards i would 100 support a
government program that pays married
couples to have kids
100
of course i would conservatives have
tried to
split the baby on this issue in recent
years and so they'll say well we'll give
you a child tax credit well will allow
you to deduct certain things from your
taxes and we'll allow you to file in
this way and will allow you to save
money in this way for college or then
it hasn't worked
so it's easy for conservatives to get
discouraged and say well then nothing's
going to work if we use our politics but
it might just be that we haven't done
enough or we haven't done the right
things because hungary for instance and
to a lesser degree russia have taken
more drastic measures to redu reduce the
the or to reverse the declining
population
and it's worked it totally in hungary it
totally worked you finally saw an uptick
again in the population and russia if
you believe russia's numbers seems to
have seen the same sort of thing
you need safeguards you need but you
can't
you can't have a civilization if you
don't have any people
okay you can't have a country without
people
and you can't
endlessly prop up a country by
ignoring national borders ignoring
immigration law completely upending your
culture that's not going to work either
encouraging sterility and and
promiscuity you're not going to have a
civilization that way at a certain point
you've got to defend those bedrock
institutions the foundational
institution is marriage is the family
and you've got to have people that's
your main resource
as a country and i think conservatives
are getting woke
not in the leftist sense of woke but
they're just kind of waking up to the
problems of some failed policy and
they're recognizing if we don't have
people we're not going to have a country
and they're moving in that direction
you're blake master's talking about this
kind of stuff he's running for senate in
arizona you hear jd vance he's running
for senate in ohio you hear a lot of the
national conservatives talking about
this a lot of the integralist
conservatives talking about this you
hear some humble podcasters such as
myself talking about this this is
the future
all right and when elon musk
and pope francis
and
jd vance all agree on on a policy let's
do it let's go for it okay now not all
ways
of promoting childbirth are okay all
right we do need a little bit of a
warning here there is a really sad story
out of the wall street journal
about a grieving family
who had a kid who had all sorts of
problems and addiction and
turns out that the addiction and the
mental illness ran in the family and
they didn't know that not because the
baby was adopted
they didn't know that because the baby
was conceived using some other random
dude's sperm that they plucked out of a
catalog and they didn't do their due
diligence and they didn't know the
background of this guy whose sperm they
purchased
and as a result
one the child was conceived without
knowing his natural father and two
the child had to deal with all of these
problems ultimately the child
dies really really sad story
but a lesson to all of us as we consider
these problems of how do we rebuild the
family how do we rebuild
the country
so here's here's the story from the wall
street journal a grieving family wonders
what if they had known the medical
history of sperm donor
1558 stephen gunner battled mental
illness before a fatal overdose
turns out his biological father had his
own psychiatric problems
really sad stuff
the road to hell is paved with good
intentions and the road to hell is paved
with good desires
but you can't let a good end
allow you to justify for yourself
immoral means
we can't do this stuff okay it's not
good and the pro-life movement focuses
so much as it should on abortion that it
sometimes ignores some other issues but
but not all ways of of creating a baby
are moral or okay
and we're going to need to talk
seriously about that especially as we're
dealing with this
problem of a dying population
a child has a right
to his natural mother and father who are
who are bonded bound together through
marriage
and we're changing all of that now and
we're having people conceive babies
because they'll go into a catalog and
pick a mother
or pick a father and they'll go into
that and they'll pick a mother and
they'll say okay i want her eggs yeah
she went to harvard and she's pretty hot
okay we're gonna pick we're gonna get
her eggs and then we're gonna find some
poor young girl who wants some money and
we're gonna rent her womb and then we're
gonna use my sperm and this woman's egg
that i just bought for a lot of money by
the way it's huge huge business and
we're gonna pay all the big medical
companies and we're going to do that and
then we're going to rent this poor
woman's uterus and then maybe it'll work
maybe it won't then we're going to have
a child and intentionally deprive that
child of his natural mother that's not
okay that's not moral that's not
right
the desire for a baby is good it's a
wonderful thing to be encouraged but a
baby is not just
property you don't have a right to a
baby okay baby is a gift from god you
got to be grateful for it but you don't
want to reduce the baby to the level of
property and you don't want to make it
all about
you
tomorrow is going to be a huge day for
the daily wire and the lawsuit against
the biden administration over this
disgusting vaccine mandate that they are
pushing
the supreme court is going to hear oral
arguments on the legality and
constitutionality of
biden's medical tyranny
we already have over a million
signatures on our do not comply petition
we really appreciate this
this gives us a lot of support going
into this legal battle
if you haven't realized in recent years
that the court looks at the polls that
the court looks at public opinion then
you have not been paying attention they
do we need your support still head on
over
sign the petition send it to your
friends and family dailywire.com
do not comply and say that you
do not stand
for this medical tyranny that the biden
administration is pushing on us we'll be
right back with a lot more
speaking of future generations
in the past 24 hours
i have become
an nft
mogul
yes
i'm a crypto king
i am i'm a tech wizard i don't know what
any of these things are really
but i
i heard about the non-fungible tokens
that's an nft
and that is as far as i can tell a
digital representation
of
an image or a tweet or some kind of
digital property so i thought it would
be funny
to dip my toes in the waters of nfts and
crypto i
minted
an nft this digital token of my tweet
announcing
five years ago my blank book
reasons to vote for democrats so if
you're it's kind of hard to follow i
created a digital kind of nothing
of a of a tweet which is kind of nothing
about a book which doesn't have any
words in it it's nothing
and i auctioned this off
and a really discerning art collector
paid
1492 dollars for it
the 1492 you might recall is the year
that columbus sailed the ocean blue it's
great
elisa sweet little alisa did not want me
to take this money she thought it was
wrong because she
bizarrely thought that my tweet wasn't
worth anything
it's insane i did i instead of wanting
to donate it to charity i wanted to
transfer it to my local cigar shop we're
still debating this you feel free to
weigh in in the comments section
but it did raise this question to me are
the nfts worthless
i i don't think they're necessarily
worthless we're all joking about it now
oh what it's nothing it's just a what i
can't even hold what does it mean well
first of all
if you've got a painting an original
painting and you've got a an embellished
print
you know a print where it's got kind of
the contours of the paint on it if you
look at the original and the print
very often you can't tell the difference
but there is a difference one is worth
100 bucks one is worth
ten thousand dollars
why well because one is the original and
it's just even though they look
identical one is the original okay i
kind of get that analogy
furthermore
i think nfts might not be a total scam
because
they potentially could have value in the
metaverse
walmart just came out with this
dystopian terrifying clip of how they
expect you to go shopping in the
metaverse the metaverse is when you put
on your virtual reality goggles and you
sit in your little pod and we're always
quarantining for the rest of our lives
and you go and you go through a virtual
aisle and you buy pick up the virtual
bottle of wine and the virtual
strawberries and then they just ship it
to you and you just get it at your door
and that's that and there are three
companies that you shop at and you get
everything so in that digital world if
as mark zuckerberg thinks we're going to
be socializing in the digital world we
started it during covid
during what some have called a great
reset where you you would get drinks
online on zoom you'd catch up with your
family on zoom well what if you did this
in this fully immersive experience if
that happens then having a digital
property like a non-fungible token would
would be much more valuable than a than
a physical property if i have a physical
wristwatch if i have a physical handbag
if i have a physical leftist tears
tumbler that ain't worth jack in the
metaverse but if i have the nft then it
is so why do i think this could happen
because it sounds so hellish and hideous
and dystopian
that of course we're gonna do it right
of course our
ruins of a civilization that we're
living in is headed in that direction
and so
i do think there is a slight chance i
hope we can stave off that virtual
reality but just think about how how
much closer the ruling class has pushed
us toward living in a virtual world even
the push for transgenderism
which my friend james pulas at the
claremont institute observes is probably
just uh
dipping your toes in the waters of
transhumanism right this idea that our
bodies don't matter i'm a man but i feel
like a woman so i'm just going to say
that i'm a woman now the physical world
doesn't matter well if you're in the
metaverse you can you can look like
marilyn monroe you can look like audrey
hepburn even if you're some big fat
hairy dude
that would be
an ideological inducement down that step
this is clearly where the liberal
establishment the ruling class is trying
to take us do we have the hoods but do
we have do we have the
will to live to to pull out of that i
don't know we're a dying population can
we turn that around i certainly hope so
speaking of
non-fungible things
joe manchin democrat senator from west
virginia not fungi
he is not he is not moving he is not
changing his views he's not substituting
one he is standing firm
against joe biden's budget
the build back better plan which
republicans are calling build back broke
the white house
you remember said we're working with joe
manchin and then a couple weeks ago he
said nope no thanks he goes on the fox
news sunday show he says i'm out i hate
this i'm not doing it this bill sucks
everyone despises it and my constituents
are going to throw me out we're not
we're not doing it
so then
the white house said oh well no anyway
never mind and now recently just a few
days ago the white house said look
regardless of what joe manchin said on
television we're talking we're
negotiating so what does mansion do he
comes out again he says no we're not no
we're not don't believe what they're
saying this thing is dead
he said quote i'm really not going to
talk about buildback better because i
think i've been very clear on that there
is no negotiation going on
at this time whether they're talking or
not mansion is really putting on a good
a good show here for the
conservatives and for his constituents
who hate it joe manchin knows this is a
loser with voters joe manchin knows that
there are now 24 house democrats who are
retiring this year rather than run for
re-election
24 because they know the map looks
devastating for them
to put that in perspective there are
only 11 house republicans who aren't
running for reelection every couple
years there are a number of congressmen
of both parties who say okay i've had
enough i've been here for
700 years already so i'm gonna i'm gonna
quit but you've got more than double the
number of democrats who are retiring
as republicans because they know this
looks really bad
there is one republican who just retired
from congress
that man's name
devin nunes sorry to see him go he was
one of the good guys he really fought
very hard for conservative causes
one of mr nunez's colleagues just read
his resignation letter into the record
i write to inform you that i have
notified california governor gavin
newsom of my resignation from the u.s
house of representatives effective today
at 11 59 p.m it has been the honor of my
life to represent the people of
california's san joaquin valley for the
last 19 years please let me help know
how i can be of help during this
transition signed sincerely devin nunes
member of congress
so he resigns he's out why is he out
because he's running a new media venture
for donald trump is he just out because
he wants to make some more money is he
just out because he really really likes
donald trump
no he's been in congress a long time but
i think the reason that congressman
nunes who is one of the good guys who
was a really hard worker really
important in exposing the corruption
behind the russiagate investigation and
effectively the dnc slash deep state
coup to undermine the trump
administration both before and after it
got elected
i think nunes realizes that he just
can't do very much in congress
he can just do more outside of congress
jim demint great conservative senator he
left
the senate to go run the heritage
foundation why because he felt that he
could do much more outside of the senate
than he could do in the senate and i
think that's probably true
and that hasn't always been the case
the way we were told that our government
works is that there's the white house
there's the executive the the
legislature and the judiciary and the
bills and the spending and the laws they
start in the legislature and i'm a bill
up on capitol hill and i'm i'm standing
here on whatever you know and then the
bills are debated and then they get
passed and then they go to the white
house and they're either approved or
vetoed and then if there's some question
about their constitutionality they go to
the judiciary and that's just not really
how it works
the members of congress
do not pass the laws
bureaucrats working in the executive
agencies for all intents and purposes
write all of our laws
and congress decides to spend some money
sometimes or not spend some money or
maybe they'll name a post office or
maybe they'll grill senators will grill
some nominees for various positions but
they don't have as much power as they
used to have
they mostly just go on tv and talk they
mostly just they mostly just do this
they're they're like podcast hosts with
much smaller audiences a lot of the time
and so i think what nunes realized is
okay well if i'm effectively just a
podcast host especially when the
republicans are out of power
especially when i'm in the minority
party then i've really got nothing to do
okay i'm just gonna go do this because
that's where the power is and i think
conservatives need to
recognize that
there's a big difference between what
the constitution says
the capital c constitution and the
lowercase c constitution of how our
countries actually run
and we need to focus our efforts
on the latter on where the real power is
this was one of the flaws with for
instance the tea party movement and with
a lot of conservative activism in the
last few decades
is we'll go on and on and we'll say but
the constitution but this is what it
says in the constitution and no one
cares nobody cares at all and so we can
we can yell and scream until we're blue
in the face and we can be totally right
by the letter of the constitution but it
won't matter because the left controls
the actual institutions of power and the
institutions that conservatives used to
control
the military at least we had some
control over we had some control still
in the government some control in
corporate america and we had the family
remember that we that was the main
institution that we had and that's that
was the silent majority and the great
the great way to resist political
activism
from the higher levels well those have
all been rotted out
so i think we need to focus in more on
the real
the real power centers and so i salute
congressman nunes i think he made a good
good choice speaking of what
ex-politicians are up to less savory
politicians
andrew cuomo is getting off the hook
andrew cuomo
was in legal trouble not because he sent
a bunch of senior citizens to go to
nursing homes to die during kovid but
because he allegedly winked at his
secretary or something he got in trouble
for all sorts of sexual harassment
issues that i thought were trumped up
from the very beginning
and i know that a lot of conservatives
glommed onto these and they said oh we
got him he's a pervert he's a sicko he's
a sexist i thought i i don't know that i
totally buy this i think these sexual
issues are coming up at a very
politically convenient time we haven't
heard them before they're only coming up
now when he's weak because of the kovid
scandal and it would seem that the
albany district attorney agrees the
albany d.a david sores is expected to
drop criminal charges of forcible
touching against andrew cuomo
days before he's
arraigned this is just bare-knuckle
politics okay
this is just the usual i'm so skeptical
of basically any sex scandal
even of degenerates like bill clinton or
people that we know even anthony weiner
you know that guy obviously is guilty as
sin of weird creepy sex stuff but even
when the first sex scandal broke i
thought well maybe i'm not because
they're just such such commonplace and
they're so easy and they usually go away
when people take their
the accused political power away so
they're usually just kind of convenient
andrew cuomo lost power not because he
allegedly touched his secretary but
because
of the covet scandals and because he was
a huge liability for the democrat party
and for their their pretense of
leadership under covid and so he got
weakened and so
there were a bunch of trumped-up sex
charges that were they were never really
going to take to court but he's out of
power
period
when are we going to see that kind of
accountability
from the higher levels of the democratic
party
i'm not so sure jen saki jensaki
the poor beleaguered press secretary for
joe biden
was asked about the president's covet
strategy and you you would imagine at
this point with such a high disapproval
rating including concluding on covet the
press might ask jinsaki hey is is joe
biden going to reverse course go a
little perhaps back off of the mandates
perhaps back off of some of these
lockdowns that are not very effective
is he going to do that
and instead what does the press ask jan
saki
they say hey jen
when
is the president
going to get even tougher on covid when
is the president going to get even
meaner and crueler and more disparaging
of the american people when is the
president going to scold his
constituents
more
really bad leadership on kovid from the
white house and from more importantly
our media some
flack in the white house press corps
asks jen saki hey jen the leader of
france just said that he was going to
quote piss off
his unvaccinated constituents
so when is joe biden going to do the
same thing
french president emmanuel macron said
this week that he plans to hassle the
vac on vaccinated to try to get them to
get the shot since there are millions of
americans who have not been persuaded by
uh you know the various government
campaigns to get vaccinated does
uh you know why hasn't the president
focused more on kind of scolding the
unvaccinated to try to tell them hey
this is not working for society
you know we keep getting these shutdowns
well i would say that um
if you look just to a little over a year
ago last december only about a third of
the american people were willing to get
a shot and today over 85 percent of
american adults have at least one shot
uh and more than 70 percent are fully
vaccinated so our our objective has been
to
continue to convey to the american
people the fact that getting vaccinated
will help protect them from
hospitalization from death that will
help protect their loved ones
it will help protect their neighbors and
their community
and we've had a great deal of success in
that
and obviously the french will make their
own decisions about the most effective
way to communicate with their public
i actually like that little barb at the
end there
look the french maybe that's just the
way the french talk is we hate you you
disgusting peasants yes that'll show you
but what's shocking here is not saki's
answer or joe biden's continued failed
policy on covid
it's the reporter it's the press these
people
truly are the enemy of the people
they are when donald trump used that
phrase the enemy of the people
even i i'm fairly bloodthirsty i
recoiled a little i thought that's a
little harsh
donald come on don't they are they're
the enemy of the people they hate the
people they hate you they hate that you
have any power they themselves are not
speaking truth to power other than the
meager power that you might still have
left they they are not they are they are
petitioning the powerful the ruling
class
to take even what little joys and powers
and way of life that you have left to
take that away from you
they are
little tattletails in elementary school
they are hall monitors they're they're
saying hey jen
jen you're not
they're still they're not doing what i
want them to do can you be meaner to
them jen can joe biden do that
disgusting
disgusting these people something has
gone seriously wrong with the
relationship of the press to the
government and to the people this is why
no one listens to them anymore this is
why no one has any respect for the
corporate journalists nor should they
they do not deserve one iota of respect
by the way though biden is following
that suggestion he is scolding the
american people he just came out and
whined and complained and yelled and
said there's no excuse not to get the
fouchy algae
you know we've reduced the number of
american adults
without any shots from 90 million
to about 35 million in the past six
months but there's still 35 million
people
not vaccinated
and let me be absolutely clear
we have in hand all the vaccines we need
to get every american fully vaccinated
including the booster shot
so there's no excuse
no excuse for anyone being unvaccinated
this continues to be a pandemic of the
unvaccinated
so we got to make more progress
no it isn't it isn't it isn't
a an epidemic of the unvaccinated
even the cdc are admitting this
even the fda even fauci even even you
know this yourself because you know we
all know people who have the vaccines
who have the booster shots who have all
of these things and they've gotten
covered
now you might say well they but the they
didn't go to the hospital they didn't
die their symptoms were reduced maybe
yeah okay fine whatever but they still
got it and they're still spreading it at
least to some degree
we are all in agreement on that here you
know because i don't want big tech to
censor me
big
public health genius experts take it
away please explain to me how joe
biden's wrong
what they can't do anymore is prevent
transmission you know we didn't have
vaccines that block transmission we got
vaccines to help you with your health
but they only slightly reduce the
transmissions we need a new
new way of doing the vaccine the level
of virus in the nasopharynx
of a person who's vaccinated and
infected
is the same level
as the level of virus in the nasal
parents of an unvaccinated person
reports from our international
colleagues including israel
suggest increased risk of severe disease
amongst those vaccinated early
and if you look at israel
which has always been a month to a month
and a half
ahead of us they are seeing
a waning of immunity not only against
infection
but against hospitalizations and to some
extent death a booster might actually be
an essential part
of the primary regimen that people
should have
you get it you get the idea
it's not it's not a pandemic of the
unvaccinated and when joe biden says
there's no excuse not to get it there
plenty of excuses one there are there
are side effects and people have died
and faced serious conditions like blood
clots like inflammation of the heart
like nerve damage and there are
religious questions and moral questions
because all of the vaccines were
developed with and some were produced
with the stem cells of aborted babies so
there are plenty of reasons not to get
the vaccine okay and
what we're seeing here is frankly it's
the same issue as we see with january
6th the vaccine should not be that big
of a deal
because
the virus relative to other pandemics in
history is really not that big of a deal
the lockdowns are a huge deal the
political campaign to completely upend
our society that's a big deal but the
virus itself relative to other epidemics
is not as big a deal okay
and when we focus on it all the time and
we kind of have to these days because of
the way that this virus has been used as
an excuse to completely upend our
political order but when we make
everything about the virus when we make
everything about you have to get the
vaccine or you should never ever get the
vaccine or the when you you're you're
buying into their premise
that it's all about
the science and it's all about this one
particular illness and it's all about
the
the whims and decrees of dr fauci what
we need to do here is not
accept the rigged game that the left is
giving us whether we're talking about
the public health establishment whether
we're talking about
the riot at the capitol or whether we're
talking about our democracy or anything
else
we need to focus on things that matter
as best we can we need to not play their
game we need to not give in to their
premises we need to live our lives we
need to ignore their stupid rules we
need to go meet our friends go to
christmas do our jobs
stop wearing all of the nonsense and
jumping up on a pogo stick on one leg
which is going to be the next
public health measure that they're going
to tell us to do
we need to stop
talking about the great
terrible most awful worst day ever
january 6th then we need to go celebrate
and i recommend we start celebrating on
the feast of the epiphany i'm michael
knowles this is the michael and all show
i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022. on
the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show